Now let's look at the interface that's available for
the stub that is on the client side and the
server side through the subcontract mechanism. The first interface, of
course, is for marshaling and unmarshaling. So the client side
stub has to marshal the arguments form the client
and in order to do that, it has calls that
it can make on the subcontract saying that marshal these
arguments for me. The subcontract will do that for you.
Depending on whether this invocation is going to
go to a server that is on the network
or is it on the same machine. Or, is
it on different processor on the same machine? All
of those details are buried in the subcontract. And
therefore, when the client stub wants to marshal the
arguments for a particular invocation, it just calls the
subcontract and says please marshal these arguments for me,
and the subcontract knows the way in which this
particular invocation is going to be handled, and so it
can then do the appropriate thing for marshaling the
arguments based on where the location of the server is.
That's the beauty of the subcontract mechanism, and this
is true on the server side as well as on
the client side. And once the marshaling has been
done, the client side can make the invocation. And when
it makes the invocation, once again the subcontract says
I know exactly where this particular invocation is going to
go to. So it takes care of that. So
the subcontract on the client side has this invocation mechanism
obviously because the client is the guy that is
going to make the invocation. On the service side the
subcontract gives a different set of mechanisms. It allows the
server to revoke a service, or it allows a server
to tell the subcontract that yes, I'm open
for business by saying I'm ready to process invocation
requests. So what you see is that the
client side and the server side, the boundary is
right here. The client stub and the server
stub don't have to do anything differently, whether the
client and the server are in the same machine
or in a different machine. Replicas of the machine,
cache copies of the machine, none of those things
make a difference in terms of what the client,
when I say client I mean the client application
plus the client stub, and similarly, the server plus
the server stub, they don't have to do anything
different. All of the magic happens down below in
the subcontract mechanism. So to recap, the innovations in
the spring system. It uses object technology as a structuring
mechanism in building a network operating system
and it ensures through the object technology
that it is providing strong interfaces, it is open, it is flexible, and it is
also extensible because it is not a monolithic kernel. It has a microkernel, and
all the services are provided through these
object mechanism living on top of the kernel.
And the other nice property is that the clients and the servers don't have to
know whether they are colocated on the same
node or they exist on different nodes of
the local area network. And object invocations
across the network are handled through the network
proxies. And the subcontract mechanism allows the client
and the servers to dynamically change the relationship
in terms of who they are talking to. You can get new instances of
servers instantiated and advertise that through the subcontract
mechanism so that the clients can dynamically bind to
new instances of servers that have been
created without changing anything in the client side
application or the client side stub. So those
are all the powers that exist when you
decide how to innovate under the covers, which
is exactly what Sun did with the spring system.